STEPHANIE WONG:
Today we're talking
about Apigee wins, our
commitment to EU customers,
and VM fleet-wide monitoring.
I'm Stephanie Wong, and
welcome to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you
the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
APIs let developers easily
access, combine, and share
valuable data and functionality,
helping companies adapt
to disruption and reinvent.
So partnering with the
right API management vendor
is critical to
building and scaling
a successful API program.
We're excited to share
that Gartner has recognized
Google Apigee as a
leader in the 2020 Magic
Quadrant for full
lifecycle API management,
marking the fifth time in a row
we've earned this recognition.
In this year's report,
Apigee is placed
highest among all the vendors
for the ability to execute.
Congrats team.
In recent months, European
customers and policymakers
have placed even more emphasis
on working with cloud providers
to protect customers' most
sensitive information.
Google Cloud has
partnered with them
to make significant progress
to delivering more capabilities
for strict data security
and privacy requirements.
They reflect three distinct
pillars of data, operational,
and software sovereignty.
Read Thomas Kurian's
announcement in the blog
post to learn more.
You can now monitor your compute
VM fleet's health all together.
The new single pane of
glass infrastructure summary
dashboard lets you see
aggregate fleet-wide statistics
at a glance, and
provides insight
into the top VMs for a select
group of key CPU, disk, memory,
and network metrics.
Jumpstart your troubleshooting.
No setup required.
Check out the blog post
to learn all about it
and try it out for yourself.
Finally, the director
of product management
of artificial
intelligence has just
announced that PyTorch XLA
support for Cloud TPUs is now
generally available.
This means PyTorch users
can access large scale,
low cost TPU
hardware accelerators
using a stable, well-supported
PyTorch integration.
Google Cloud supports a
growing set of open source
implementations of widely
used deep learning models
and associated tutorials.
Check out our post for tutorials
and how to get started.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.